[Music]
in powertrip news oh man
submitted by the one Keanu Reeves
he's v1 I am Number One remember that
one when P Diddy was oh yeah yeah when
you thought he was a rapper yeah when
was that like I've never considered P
Diddy he hung the rapper he thinks he's
a rapper he looks like Satan dude I like
the it's all about the Benjamins baby I
like that one baby was that P Diddy and
I'm just saying black rappers names know
everything here we go a compliant a
complaint a complaint a complaint was
filed with the NYPD after a female
sergeant humiliated one of her
detectives by house yeah you forgot the
pain you're actually listening to
complaints now that's [ __ ] crazy it's
an internal complaint right like against
one another yes detective look like just
regular monocle oh okay
they have to have that [ __ ] police
hat from the UK right like you're really
tall in the u.s. they just wear like a
regular dress shirt I don't believe have
to see them all right so this Brooklyn
sergeant
named and like all those background
noises so her name is Anne Marie Anne
Marie she's 38 years old
see European Guerra
yo yo yo yo that sounds like a Mexican
she allegedly humiliated this detective
named Victor by telling him that a like
his female love interest was probably
not into him because he
small dick tight and sounds like fun
banter yeah that sounds like office talk
dude yeah I don't know what led up to
this like it's funny he [ __ ] reported
that [ __ ] no let me tell you the rest
that he recorded all the time I probably
called you little dick to it yeah you're
never a bother to play Bart Bart Bart
have you posted with panic was gonna be
it oh he punished me alright silent
you [ __ ] douchebag I wanna lie you
know maybe punish me alright he locked
me outside the other thing that this
sergeant did was so they have this co-ed
bathroom at the station house and she
would frequently shower and then leave
her underwear hanging on like the shower
knob and it's unisex like other people
use that too oh my god yeah so then they
were just like there were complaints
like they were complaining to her like
can you pick up your dirty underwear
like they're just laying around it's
pretty disgusting do you have a picture
of it though is it like skid marks all
of that [ __ ] but I don't think it's
something to complain like her like a
power trip I guess she is part is that
part well I'm about to get to that power
trip report so she ends up saying like
she yells at them saying like they're
clean see she stopped her panties in
this dude lucky you that's what you find
it appends on what she looks like
what did she do that so I'll show your
photo right now she's a mom of two oh
and she also told people around the
station that she uses a dildo on her
husband and as she like talks about her
sex life a lot I see what kind of person
she is what kind of person is she crazy
she's the one that likes to dominate
people and it makes her horny that's why
she stuffs panties in people's mouths
and leave them around everywhere
everyone is Trail yeah she's like
marking her territory yeah but she
stuffed her underwear the dismount
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's justified
er I was thinking that - someone punched
me in the face have to do it I'd be like
alright
15 15 years ago though I'll be okay with
it
15 yeah what was poppin 15 years ago she
was probably really hot oh you at a
younger age is like oh this is totally
okay you like oh no she's perfect we
could both be 15 years ago I think it'll
be fine
how did you she's an attractive woman
though yeah oh yeah no never my doll is
a bad picture this one's well it's nice
to though she's attractive especially in
that industry she's probably really
attractive yeah she's a sergeant there's
a lot of hot cops though yeah not that
many maybe cuz I live right next to a
police station and it's like a [ __ ]
huge one I see so many I'm just like
[ __ ] I never knew and it's some Sun come
all [ __ ] glammed up and [ __ ] and some
of them are like the the the suit
detective one and they got the little
badge on the side I'm all like why are
you dressing like that you're a police
officer
and I'm like dressing like sexy already
like like like a skirt that's super
tight but like it's like a business like
a pencil skirt yeah you're wearing like
a [ __ ] shirt but like it's like how
you gonna fight crime with those titties
they're like a beat cop though I feel
like I'm doing something inside row no
but then they're the [ __ ] stilettos
are like this huge or whatever I suppose
I'm like what are you a [ __ ] hooker
detective you're mixing you're born with
what you saw oh maybe not the stilettos
okay but maybe it was pumps all I'm
saying it was more appropriate but still
I think just I was like damn that's
crazy how like you get to just like that
will work it's like a porno
a pencil skirt is the skirt goes higher
and it's a little bit it's a little bit
form-fitting but then it goes all the
way to the bottom like here I don't know
how that's know there's that cuz she's
showing those [ __ ] sexy eyes but
there's some guys like up to the knee
and [ __ ] I don't know I was just like
that's still very appropriate I know
no pass to me passing me like higher
than a little bit yeah like an inch
above the knee that's the very
appropriate but then the way that it bit
on that person though because they're
measure is this like if it's if it can't
be shorter than your finger your longest
finger right but like if a person is hot
right like or if they have a nice booty
like it pops even if it's a very
conservative thing to wear okay yeah so
it doesn't matter what the where
everything is a second that's their body
that's the problem
yeah he's not a problem I don't think
you think it's a problem it's not a
problem at all I was just surprised okay
okay I was like wow she's hot
yeah and there are a lot of like strong
looking buff women those are the ones
that I'm used to like there's a there's
a general female cop shape yes yeah
that's the majority that I mean because
dependent like if you're working and
like on the field
yeah then you have to be sturdy I'm just
saying that generally there's a feel
like you know just that female cop
haircut you when they turn around and
you see a doughnut right there yeah yeah
yeah there's a general shape yeah
whenever the patrolling though those are
the cops you talk yep and then those are
the ones in the uniform yeah yes but
they're also the ones that become
Detective later on I'm really hot I
don't notice them what the [ __ ] you even
know know you name the pencils Ravens
yeah I don't notice them is it wrong
that I have a hard time finding what's
wrong with what's been reported so far I
thought you said is it wrong that I have
a hard on
I was preparing myself for that cuz in
that type of industry like I people talk
[ __ ] they talk [ __ ] like crazy they'll I
know if I want to get like under my
mouth that seems a bit aggressive and
then it's like pretty I mean I get it
you know the whole culture like it's
very blue-collar
yes I feel like there's a double
standard though because if I was a her
sergeant and I stuffed my underwear in
her mouth
that's me to tag me too she's getting in
trouble there's a I'm just saying like
in Bart's world right in Bart's world
but in my world this is okay right
but it feels the other way around I
would not be okay I'm saying with like a
six foot five black dude shoving his
boxers into like a five foot girl's
mouth and his whole fist went inside - I
would not be okay with that
you see it's clean oh yeah another thing
they mentioned that she would say is
that she told other cops at once one
time that she was home alone
masturbating and her husband came home
and that he tried to join her and she
said what the [ __ ] this isn't an
invitation I just thought that was funny
that was part of the complaint I don't
know that's why I think this guy is just
weird
because yeah it's her like so in the cop
world but everyone works patrol right
and when you're on patrol you're driving
eight to twelve hours a day with the
same person you end up talking about
everything and it's a blue-collar
environment so because of that like my
god wouldn't be surprised if one day you
showed up to work and there's a pile of
[ __ ] on your desk and it's because it's
an inside joke of something you know and
it's supposed to be normal
sergeant he's a detective
it's like she's above him so it's like a
whole she owns is s it's really hard for
me to find like I don't know from I
watch this show called Dexter and
sergeant Doakes was an [ __ ] yeah he
would just come up to Dexter and call
him a little [ __ ] and all this other
stuff so I thought that's just how it
rolls this is a professional sergeant
Doakes was meanest [ __ ] dude what you
looking at some prize money because if
you came to me
and like let's say you're that guy
complaining and you came to me and you
were like this is all my boss did today
I'd be so pissed
what do you mean uh if you were like hey
this lady just shoved her [ __ ]
underwear my mouth what would you do
shove your underwear in her mouth about
it they'd be dirty what did i do what
did I do to make her do that to me it
doesn't matter I just feel like that's
uncalled but she doesn't do that to
everybody yeah well they do say well not
the penny stuffing in the mouth but the
thing that she does to it do to everyone
is actually spouts man-hating
rhetoric about her fellow sergeants
having questions the only female than
that into her department yeah I don't
like her it sounds like she's
overcompensating for her constant like
feeling of you know needing to Dom like
she needs to be absolutely yeah she
needs to prove her so she has to be like
a tough person yeah that's what it
sounds like yeah
and it just so happens that she's a lady
coz I can see this happening with the
small man syndrome you know someone
that's always been 7m 7 well yeah so
it's just in this situation because of
the gender differences it's it's it's
it's like a snoo controversial thing yes
like she's 80 in one picture and then
she looks like she's right I'm saying
man she looks like those 80 year old
ladies that are still kind of hot and
trying to hold on to their 20s yeah all
right 38 38 she looks like [ __ ] here for
38 she looked she doesn't look 38 and
shimmy cubes from this thing I think
it's our posture is that a functional
belt that's funny cuz the guns gonna go
I should pause the gun the whole [ __ ]
thing I think she looks good for 38
really I think I don't like her but I
think you mean 38 in a cop like yeah
that's true 38 cop probably on like a
bunch of fistfights
I get the judges she shoved pennies down
another man's throat if I was a woman
I'd be like [ __ ] yeah it's about time
[ __ ] that's how I feel like that
looks nice
you know what it is it's because they
took that photo on a Nokia that's why
really grainy and must be all that daesh
weren't a peacoat to a photo shoot it's
New York all right she looks nice like
she doesn't seem like a mean person
right that photo that photo she looks
nice she look like a [ __ ] to me she
looks like she looks like somebody gotta
like let you borrow butter and [ __ ] when
you run out of butter at your house
imagine like answering the door with
like the gun looks like a dress really
oh no it's cooler but the other picture
yeah I belong yo you got any butter man
yo you don't got the Kerrygold son I
didn't mean it scratch I got itchy they
need that pure [ __ ] man it's unsalted
[Music]
[Music]